pharming as we now associate the word
has been around for about seven to ten
thousand years and when we think of
farming we imagine a farmer planting
seeds and later harvesting the crops or
maybe having cattle that they can allow
to graze and then using that cattle for
either meat or milk or wool but there's
actually a different type of farming
that predates this this association with
kind of I guess what we could call the
traditional flour form of farming and it
predates it by several tens of thousands
of years and we believe that it started
with it started with the original
inhabitants of Australia and what they
did is and this is why we call it
farming and because if you think about
farming in the most general sense it's
really humans using technology to
manipulate their environment so it
becomes more suitable for humans so it
becomes more suitable for things that
humans might want to eat or get milk
from or or or whatever and this type of
farming is called firestick farming
firestick farming and i think you can
already imagine what it might involve it
involves using fire which is really a
form of technology it can be a form of
technology using fire to make the
environment more suitable for for human
activity and so what the original
Australians did the indigenous
australians or sometimes referred to as
the aboriginal australians aboriginal
aboriginal australians and if you're
wondering where the word aboriginal
comes from you might recognize some
parts of it original you know what that
means the iridium the beginning and then
you have AB which is Latin for from so
this is literally from the beginning so
when you say Aboriginal Australians
you're really kind of saying the
Australians that were there from the
beginning and so what they would do is
is that we believe if you go back 50 or
60 or 60 thousand years before the first
Aboriginal Australians settled Australia
Australia had much more forests
it still has forests this is a modern
picture obviously of an Australian
forest but what they did is that they
set up controlled burns and what these
controlled burns did is
they they cleared away a lot of the
forest they cleared away a lot of the
brush that's at the bottom of you know
that's over here and it made it much
more suitable for grassland to develop
and the reason why they liked grassland
so let's make a little cycle here of
what they did so they have controlled
burns controlled controlled fires those
controlled fryers helped promote
grassland and then once you have
grassland that made the environment more
suitable for animals that that the the
original human settlers could
essentially live off of that they could
hunt that they could potentially eat
their meat and so for example things
like things like things like kangaroos
and these supported the human population
he supported the human population which
obviously would then do the controlled
burns and you see here so we could have
started off with something like this
someone provides a controlled burn and
and they were actually pretty scientific
about how they did it that they wouldn't
just go at the end of summer when
everything was you know hot and and and
ready to just blow up and they'd start a
fire that they couldn't control they
would often do these in seasons knowing
that it had a certain level of moisture
in the air as a certain it wasn't too
hot and and to a large degree by doing
these control burns not only did it
provide an environment kind of do this
firestick farming not only did it
provide an environment that was suitable
for things like kangaroos some type of
things that humans could eat but it also
prevented major fires and you still see
forest rangers doing this type of thing
and there's some there's there's some
reason to believe that what the original
Australians did on some level was more
nuanced and more fine-tuned than even
what what we do in a modern sense and
controlled burns so these controlled
fires also prevented prevented major
uncontrollable fires prevented major
fires because what happens is if you if
you don't have these controlled fires
then you have brush building up year
after year after year you have stuff
building up and then and then when the
fires do occur they're not going to
occur there or they're less likely for
the uncontrolled fires are less likely
to be started during the winter when the
air is cool or when there might be some
moisture they're more likely to occur
and
dry season so you have all this stuff
build up and then when the fire does
happen it happens in the driest season
and then what happens with all of the
stuff build up in the dry season it just
becomes it just becomes uncontrollable
one of the byproducts are actually
there's several byproducts of this
firestick farming we believe is a lot of
the grassland in Australia now might
have been more forested more forested
before and even when the first European
settlers came in the late and the late
1700s they were kind of surprised when
they went into what is now Sydney Harbor
and they said wow look at all the
grassland here it almost looks like Park
space and and then they would you know
they would let their sheep graze there
and they were surprised with because
they had driven out the the original
inhabitants and then they were surprised
when forest just started to grow up in
that grassland and it was because the
original Australians were actually
controlling that forest growth to make
it more inhabitable for things like for
things like kangaroos and then when the
when the English settlers came they
started to have you know their sheep
graze and that in those grasslands and
it also is responsible for for the
disappearance we think of many major I
guess for lack of a better word
megafauna so at you know really large
animals that that inhabited in Australia
for really millions of years until
humans showed up and this is one of them
it's just neat to look at them this is
called dripped on optimum or another way
to think of a the giant wombat and
there's fossils of the giant wombat
around 4050 thousand years ago but they
disappeared with humans showing up and
there's multiple ways that you could
think about why they disappeared they
might have and this was probably the
case they might have been more dependent
on the forest habitat on the forest
habitat or this was a more favorable
habitat for them than the grasslands
maybe because they ate leaves that were
high up or another thing is once the
forest habitat goes away they were
actually also easier to hunt down or
either way you think about it they might
have just been hunted by humans but we
do see that with humans coming to the
Australian continent you start to see
the disappearance and this isn't the
only one but there was several major
species of megafauna of super large
animals that disappeared at that time
period